(words popping)
(lighthearted music)
- So I'm Emanuel. I'm 22.
I'm originally from Illinois,
a small town named
Hampshire, I'm in school.
Full-time trying to become sports agents.
(lighthearted music)
(image popping)
(mellow jazzy music)
(mellow jazz music)
(cat meows)
(mellow jazzy music)
(image popping)
(images popping)
(mellow jazzy music)
(image popping)
(clock beeping)
I hate to do it.
Sorry, Broccoli Gal.
(clock beeps)
I'm sorry (laughs).
(upbeat music)
(indistinct)
Hey.
- Hi.
Ah, unfortunately I'm
not too good with cats.
So, I mean, she kind of
looked like a cat lady.
Not gonna lie, but not,
not in like offensive way
or anything.
You look great.
- Thank you. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
I'm Erica.
- [Emanuel] Erica.
- Well, I'm sorry you don't like cats,
but that's kind of your loss.
- Yeah. I mean.
- I chose Broccoli Gal just
because I really like broccoli.
If you don't like broccoli,
you don't like cats,
you're not for me.
Well, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Sorry, Broccoli Gal, (laughs).
- Yeah right.
(Emanuel laughs)
(clock popping)
(mellow jazzy music)
(cheerful music)
(texts sliding)
I got a Midwestern in here.
(cheerful music)
(texts sliding)
(images popping)
(cheerful music)
I'm surprised so many people
know about Giordano's here
'cause those are like the top pizza spots.
Like if you want pizza, you
go to Giordano's or Rosati's.
(clock beeping)
(cheerful music)
Damn.
I'm gonna have to go
with therealslimzaidi.
(mellow jazzy music)
Was it a bad choice?
- Hi.
Oh hi.
- Can I have a hug?
It was a bad choice.
Of course you can.
- It's nice to meet you.
- So yeah, I didn't mean
I can't relate to when we-
- Yeah, I know but-
- In the second round,
when they started talking
about the Midwest and stuff like that,
I just didn't have much to
add to the conversation.
And I know what it's
like to move somewhere
and to meet someone who's from
the same place that you are.
And it's just kind of a really
solid connect common ground
to have, so I wasn't
that surprised at all.
- You know, you seem like a great person.
- Thank you. You seem like a great person.
- Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
Aw man (laughs).
- Hey good humans. It's Milky.
We all know that dating is tough
but the (speaking in foreign language)
to the heart is the stomach.
So we wanna thank Hello Fresh
for sponsoring this portion of the video.
Hello Fresh is meal kit company
that offers a wide variety
of quick and easy recipes
that minimize prep and
make cleanup a breeze.
Personally, I struggle a lot
with figuring out what
I wanna cook for myself
so I love Hello Fresh
because their simple recipes
and fresh pre-proportioned ingredients
make cooking super easy
and cut out meal prep time
and trips to the grocery store.
And today Hello Fresh is offering
up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts.
With Hello Fresh it's super
easy to adjust your plan
and increase your order size
to help with meal planning
for large groups or to have leftovers
for lunch the next day.
This is great for me because
one of my favorite things
to do in the office is have lunch
with the rest of the Jubilee team.
So make sure to go to
hellofresh.com and use code Jubilee16
for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts.
Again, that's hellofresh.com
with the code Jubilee16
for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts.
Now let's get back into the video.
(clock beeps)
(messages sliding)
(lighthearted music)
♪ I be waiting for you ♪
(mellow music)
(sliding messages)
- I definitely feel that.
It was honestly a while ago.
I've always not always
but I've been in like
casual relationships.
So like we were able
to talk to other people
but not like get intimate
with them if that makes sense.
So real relationship.
Honestly, I haven't had one
since I was probably like in high school.
I don't know, I feel like I'm
pretty like, what's it called?
Picky, I guess.
Can't keep 'em both? (laughs)
No I'm kidding, this was
actually really tough,
but unfortunately I'm gonna have to go
with the infamous Drug Lord.
- Hello, it's Dr. Drug Lord.
- Hey Drug Lord, what's up?
- Am I what you thought I would be?
- Actually yeah, pretty girl.
- Sweet.
Yeah.
- That's interesting.
I feel like neither of us
look like very Midwestern people though.
You know what I mean?
- We don't.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] You gonna give her a hug?
Yeah, let's go.
- Okay.
- It's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Sorry like it had to happen
this way like (laughs).
(indistinct)
- [Woman] So would you
like to meet your pick?
- Yeah, let's do it.
(upbeat music)
(indistinct)
♪ Night and day night and day ♪
(upbeat music)
- Hey.
- Hey, what's up.
- Nice to meet you.
- Am I what you expected?
- Well, I mean, like I said,
I like to like keep a plain canvas,
but I mean, you're beautiful so-
- Thank you (laughs).
- Can't see why now we can
can't make something work.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Well, if Rosati's is
still on the table, so-
- Oh yeah.
I mean, I didn't even know
there's one over here.
Definitely going to Rosati's I guess.
- Yeah (laughs).
- Two Mid westerns.
- I know,
I also sorta kind of only been
there a few times, but so-
- Yeah? Cool.
Yeah.